I mean look I don't need this headline
to get me excited about flip life but
I'm going to say it again as I'm reading
through my DMs in 2024 if you want to
make a little side cash and you're not
sitting with a lot of money call it 500
bucks or less to your name the flip life
is the life this is a very rare
occurrence but a little less rare than
you would think and more importantly the
amount of items that are bought for3
four5 $6 at Goodwill thrift stores and
sold for $30 4050 67 the after you do a
couple of weeks of learning and
education is quite common and then you
get into garage sale season where you
can buy unlimited stuff for a dollar or
two and flip it for 20 30 40 50 this is
just a video for everyone as you go into
2024 we just spent a lot of money on the
holidays I know people are thinking
about finances New Year's resolution get
a little grind going on the flip life
maybe you'll find a miracle like this
but you'll find tons of singles and
doubles and Grand Slams do happen like
above